I call this the high school party rule I
think this is the most interesting move
in high school culture if you're a mid
tier popular person you can't be the
coolest and you can't be a nerd and Off
the Grid like in the rank of 300 coolest
kids in your class you are 200 you're
below the middle if you're lucky enough
that your parents don't give a [__] or
travel too much or something else in
your environment if you are able to
somewhere between sophomore and junior
year of high school host the party and
get everybody to come to your house and
[__] on your house but you held it you
go from 200 to 990 2 to 13 if you think
back to your high school the person that
was not necessarily built to be popular
freshman year who hacked the system was
the one that realized that if they
hosted the party it would Elevate their
brand within the ecosystem if you're
hosting the podcast in a very small
Niche and you're the host and you're
reaching out and saying hey Rick number
one successful commercial real estate
personality in all of Texas I'd love for
you to be a guest on my show they're
like oh [__] whoever can host the party
first wins the lrab